this true believers is a tale where two
storied parts of american culture come
together
it truly was a unicorn moment join us as
we open the vault of automobile and film
history
this is the story of florence lawrence
she was a full-blown star of the silent
film era and
she is also the inventor of the turn
signal
florence started over 300 films produced
by biograph studios
her success led to a bit of wealth which
she used to buy a car
a crazy expensive purchase at the time
it was love at first drive
florence went from casual user to
automotive expert pursuing a knowledge
and expertise about cars that
outstripped even her passion for acting
she invented features to make driving
safer and more enjoyable
in 1914 she created a signaling arm for
cars that would allow drivers to
indicate when they wanted to turn
push a button and her invention raised a
flag on the bumper saying left to right
it was a great idea but sadly florence
never registered her design
versions of it popped up but it was
another 10 years before the turn signal
was patented and unfortunately by
somebody else
and that's when things took a turn for
the worse she lost most of her wealth in
the stock market crash of 1929 and was
injured in a fire on set
she never recovered her earlier success
once the biggest movie star in the world
now all but forgotten
but the fact remains she was a pioneer
both as an actor and as a car enthusiast
and even as she fades from memory her
contribution to cars remains
[Music]
you